let me know so here's sorry
so let's say now it's up to ten months i
said six months it went six
eight now that i realized it was just
before covered because covet happened
and we talked we
he and i had talked on the phone a lot
it was a few times it was it was weird
right
so he wanted to talk to me no big deal
but like i said i'll talk to you because
he just wants to talk to you like about
what though he just his was basically
business ideas like what do you think i
should do like i own a
piece of property and he's got like half
a mill i'm gonna go with not the exact
number but it's roughly about
half a million dollars in equity i own
it's half a million in equity
i have this business it's a service
oriented business
in manhattan this guy's emailing you
well it started as an email and then it
was uh then we
then i gave my phone number because you
know he's sending an email i'm saying
you get three or four
emails and then i get frustrated or you
stop getting emails because it's like
this isn't going anywhere
or you know it's like hey it you know or
it's like you know just just here's my
[ __ ] phone number like you're not
you're not nuts so just call me because
i'm painting
and i can put it on speaker and i can
talk to you while i'm painting um
so that's what happened we started
talking and he was like you know i just
have some business ideas and i
i was wondering about real estate what
kind of real estate things do you know
i'll pay i'll pay you for your time i'll
pay them like no well just just tell me
what do you have to work with like i'm
just like whatever let's get this over
with let me see if i can help you real
quick
and if i can't and i actually you
actually want like an idea
you know look and this is the thing like
right now guys are like bro
you know what should i do with this much
money it's like nothing
because you might have six months to a
year before the the market will most
likely crash
and don't go buy a bunch of property
right now that's going to be worth
it's going to drop by 15 or 20 or 30
percent you know don't do anything right
now you know that's
like to my my i don't really have a plan
for your money
right now but he came to me and it
wasn't that it was
it was just before so i was like well
how much do you have because i got
you you could do this you could do this
or we start talking
and then a week went by i talked to him
again then covet happened then we texted
every once in a while
and then i would send him like i have a
list of people that i send
when my videos come out i just shoot off
like 30 or 40 people right like boom
boom boom boom the videos like i'll post
the video
so i said i'm one of them right and
sometimes so
then it would come down then he would
come back like hey i just watched that
bro that's a crazy story or hey what you
know whatever he's just being supportive
and he texts everyone so while we talk
and how you doing hate this hey that
whatever that's cool
this went on for 10 months about three
weeks ago
it's almost four weeks three four weeks
ago
you know five weeks ago he actually
called me and he said hey i'm gonna be
down there
my girlfriend lives in tampa never heard
about a girlfriend that lives in tampa
guys from new york the hell when did you
get a [ __ ] girlfriend that
lives in that's crazy i've never heard
this you've been texting me forever
i know about your mom i know about your
dad i know about your all kind
all kinds of stuff you know and it's
like okay he's like well when would be
good for you i'd like to come down and
actually talk to you and
uh you know i know you like coffee i'll
get you some starbucks or we can go to
lunch or whatever i was like
well i mean when are you gonna be here
yeah well uh i can come down sunday
oh like i would think that'd be i would
be secondary to when you and your
girlfriend have planned but whatever
i'm like yeah okay so sunday we'll have
uh you can come in and
you know we'll meet for dinner or lunch
no no i'm going to fly in i will have
lunch or whatever
there's no girlfriend matt he's coming
here to see your ass yeah when he showed
up he didn't i never saw a girlfriend he
said there was a girlfriend i never saw
one
so i meet the guy we meet at starbucks
he gets me starbucks we sit down i say
hey what's you know what's up he's like
yeah what's going on with
you know he's from new york yankee so
you know with this and so we talked for
a couple of minutes
and not five minutes in the conversation
it becomes i wanted to meet you
because i wanted to look you in the face
i wanted you to know i was for real
okay that you you know i'm a i'm i'm a
stand-up guy i'm that guy i'm
like okay okay and he's like and he goes
he said uh this is an amount exact
amount but he goes he goes
i need you to help me get get 500 000
was actually 600.
i helped help me get 600 000 and i went
what i mean this is like i've we've
never had that conversation
he's never even alluded to it and i went
what what what do you mean you want me
600 000
and he goes yeah he's like like you can
if i'll pay you
up front for you to train me
like if it you know whatever we'll spend
a couple days and you can train me on
what to do
to to do that whole mortgage thing
that that you did and and i'll i'll
i'll break you off like up front or
whatever and i went
well why would break me off like give me
like 20 grand or 50 grand or something
yeah well yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i went well why
wouldn't i just split split
the money with you i mean if we're going
in partners and he goes
50 50. yeah and he goes he said yeah
okay but i need the
600 000 so yeah how long would that take
to get that kind of money and i went
so 1.2 million i get half
and i want so if if i was willing so if
i set up a scam
to get 1.2 million dollars i said that
that depending on how much money you
have up front will take about a month
i could do that a month we could have
the money and he's like you said this to
him yeah and he goes he goes
he's right oh okay he's getting excited
i said right i said so if i if i do that
he goes right right i go
why would i [ __ ] need you
and he goes what and i went why would i
need you
if i was willing to get myself involved
in a in a conspiracy
why would i need you he goes well you
don't ever have to go in the bank i go i
don't have to go in the bank now
nobody you can you can do a transaction
right now
over there you don't you don't actually
have to go into the closing anymore
and i could pay someone to go in the
closing right
so why would i why do i need you why
would i give you half a million dollars
to set up a scam that i can set up
myself and take the 1.2 million
and he goes yeah but i'm saying i can do
all the work but i don't need you to do
the work
no but i mean if somebody does need to
go in the i could go in and i looked at
him and i went
well i said you do understand you're
just adding my name to the conspiracy
once you get caught
no i'm not gonna get caught and he goes
and i wouldn't it doesn't matter
even if i got caught i would never say
nothing
and i looked at him and i went you've
already got me [ __ ] up
you don't even know it i said you've all
this is
i said i'm already caught and he goes
how i said
the moment they catch you they're going
to run all
your phone numbers and your phone my
phone my number's going to come up
they're going to run matt cox pop type
on the list i go and oh look
matt cox packed up you've been talking
to him for 10 months
and you've emailed them several times
and it's been a bunch of text messages
and
oh you just you just flew down to see
them and
then a month and a half later you've got
1.2 million
and you get caught and it's almost an
identical
fraud-related scam that matt cox has run
in the past
huh that's crazy so we're not even going
to talk to mr cox we're just going to
add his name to the to the indictment
because guess what matt cox is currently
on federal probation
and you're not going to believe this he
can't even mount a defense
we know he's done as long as his name's
next to yours you can sit there and go
you could sit the thing and say i'm
going to say nothing about cox it
doesn't matter
they'll get five guys that will get on
the stand and say
that he told them in prison when he was
locked up he told them that
cox was involved they don't it look
there's double hearsay you can
you could have double hearsay in federal
prison danny
told you about me and you get to testify
about what danny said
he doesn't even have to say anything
people can just say this is what he said
five guys got up there can mr [ __ ] can i
get on the stand and say that didn't
happen of course not
you can't you're not allowed i could but
how bad is that going to be
so have you never committed fraud before
well
i see i understand how there is a
connection between me
what am i going to say it's like saying
this he goes no you understand you'd
just be planning it so you're telling me
you just be a dog at a pony show
you do understand let's say i we i plan
right now
a murder you guys are gonna go murder
this guy
you guys go murder it i'm good right
you're not good i'm good i think so
i don't think so matter of fact you two
guys will get less time than me
the person they want the most they don't
even care about the shooter they care
about me i'm getting the most time
like one they don't want one though
yeah i don't know why that's different
yeah but but basically that's the guy
that typically gets the most time
is the guy that arranged the whole thing
you know what i'm saying yeah
so you tell me when john gotti do they
want john
gotti more than they want the guys
that are actually killing people yeah
killing people they want gotti more than
that yeah right
they'll always look at look at my buddy
pete rossini's case
the two actual the guys that actually
admitted to committing the murders got
25 years
of peace pete got 40. i didn't do
anything
so what was this guy's reaction sitting
across me at starbucks
he was like he he continued this went on
for five or ten minutes where he's
trying to convince me
and i'm like bro you don't even know
you've already got me caught
what other things are you going to do
throughout the course of this entire
thing that are going to get me [ __ ] up
you just got me [ __ ] up it hasn't
started yet you've already got me jammed
up
what's going to happen as will you go
what about the people that you
i would never tell nobody it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter
i'm already screwed the moment you
picked up the phone and said
or your whatever the moment you emailed
me i don't know how he did it but
you know the moment you he sent me a
little email it was over i was over it
was done
i was done so let me ask you this if
this guy goes out tomorrow
and commits a bunch of scams i got a
problem and he gets [ __ ] up
i got a problem i would probably have a
problem you have to
really oh yeah you have to understand
that the prosecutor
knows [ __ ] this guy's done like cox has
to sit there
and in certain situations they could
actually
mention well you know mr cox is
currently on pro on uh
he's currently on um trial well on trial
for this
of course he's been arrested and placed
in prison before for the exact same scam
now if i get on the state now here's the
interesting thing
if i had gone to prison for a murder and
now i'm being charged with a scam
running some kind of bank fraud
they can't really bring up the murder
because it's a different type of charge
does that make sense yeah like there's
no
you can't relate these two charges but
you can indict me
and then say okay well well by the way
mr cox does have a history of this and
this and this
but i can't take the stand because as
soon as i take the scan stand
they're a skillful us attorney will just
destroy me
oh so you've never done this well i mean
yes i did this and that was in your last
scam right
or was that the scam before that one
which of those five what are the ten
scams you've done that you've been
caught for
because we don't know about all of them
the jury's laughing i can see
i'm done the theatrics are just i'm
screwed yeah you're [ __ ] and there's
just nothing i can do no matter what i
say i'm done i'm done i'm done
i'm just over so i'm sitting there
thinking you if you got me caught with
your very first act
god knows what will happen throughout
the whole thing you know what it's like
it's like the guy that shows up to the
fbi and says listen man i gotta tell you
something
i know about these guys that have been
robbing banks really how do you know
i've been driving the getaway car
you've been robbing banks yeah yeah i
mean what are you talking
about these guys you're drunk you're
just as guilty
so what else did you tell this [ __ ] i
mean i i i look he was actually very
he's actually a nice guy he's just
not thinking i mean it was just that
that was it i mean i'm not i'm i'm not
i'm just what did you do if they
actually did that if you actually if
this guy went out and
committed a scam right now and you were
on and
they [ __ ] dragged you and the fbi
said matt cox
oh he better hope they talk to him
before they talk to me because they talk
to me
you're done hey so do you know this guy
listen that [ __ ] let me tell you
what he did
here's what happened boom boom boom ass
danny
how's danny watch the episode episode
don't forget to subscribe please hit the
bell
i mean you know oh [ __ ] turn on
notifications go to [ __ ] prison again
because you decided to get
jump on a plane right uh yeah i i
i no no you're taking the plea how much
[ __ ] time do i gotta do this time
but yeah that's how bad it is
i